hi I'm mashad hayri a global solution
manager with Google cloud in this video
you'll get a quick overview of Google
Cloud application modernization program
or what we call Camp which is a
framework designed to help guide
organizations as they adopt new ways of
developing and modernizing their
application ecosystems
[Music]
let's be honest modernization can be
challenging
especially if you've been in the
software development industry for a
while the truth is that modernization is
a relative term depending on your
starting point it can look and mean
different things the good news and sadly
also the bad news is that there are many
ways you can go about achieving your
modernization goals depending on your
starting point but how do you make the
right choice
for many public cloud has become the
Clear Choice but they're struggling with
how to best adapt to this new
environment without disrupting their
users and their business
some have done the work of moving their
applications to the cloud but they're
not seeing much improvements in terms of
cost and performance the truth is
realizing the full benefits of cloud
computing requires more than just
lifting the old Tech and re-hosting it
on a cloud even though for many that may
be the right first step research shows
that for most there is more work to be
done cloud computing provides many
benefits that can really make life
easier for application developers and
owners but this would require some
investment in training and free thinking
for example the market is seeing great
returns but serverless products are used
but these are relatively new Concepts
and not widely adopted by the industry
when you have Google cloud offerings are
based on the same technologies that
power Google's own products our
Engineers created these tools because we
couldn't meet our audacious goals
without unconventional thinking and
Innovation from the very beginning
though we have been really committed to
staying open and sharing with others and
while for the most part this has been
effective we want to do more we want to
help make this as simple as possible for
those that are ready to take the next
steps and start to think in Cloud native
terms and make the most out of their
Cloud adoption
to be successful every organization
should create their own tailored path
towards their ideal Cloud State based on
their starting point level of comfort
and unique business needs and this my
friends brings us to camp this framework
focuses on helping our customers build
their own unique paths and apply proven
methodologies in a structured phased
approach to implement the right Tech
right processes and people related
improvements the program is designed to
help organizations discover existing
challenges and plan a course of action
that starts with the most impactful
areas of improvement
the idea is to create an iterative
approach where change is applied in
meaningful and manageable intervals on a
continuous basis how do we do that
when it comes to modernization in our
experience customers require support in
three distinct areas
first organization may want to improve
their current applications and rethink
past strategies think about the
applications that are still running on
Mainframe platforms or traditional Java
and net apps that can be containerized
for ease of management
organizations are also interested in
understanding how to build and operate
their applications using the latest
development patterns and tooling this
could include developer productivity
tools modern cice approaches software
security and even cultural and process
related topics like devops and SRE
principles and last but certainly not
least it's important to get exposed to
Advanced design topics that allow for
more flexible and performant application
designs for the future for example
designing applications that can freely
run out any cloud or Advanced usage of
apis as a tool for application expansion
by providing Hands-On workshops and
interactive sessions in each area we
helped expose decision makers and
Technologies to emerging tool sets and
processes they can deploy to achieve
their desired results
organizations are also able to choose
their level of Engagement and match
their comfort level in time and dollar
Investments as they get comfortable with
their chosen approach for customers that
need guidance on where to start they
offer a variety of Assessments covering
topics from applications and platforms
to people and processes
let's look at an example devops is a Hot
Topic that many are interested in
getting better at but it's also a
relatively New Concept in 2018 Google
acquired Dora which stands for devops
research and assessment This research is
one of the longest running efforts
focusing on devops as part of camp for
customers that are wondering about a
better devops posture they offer a
devops assessment backed by the dura
research helping organizations compare
themselves to others in the industry and
identifying how to improve most often
the improvements can be addressed by
adapting the right Tooling in which case
we will help educate the right teams and
make sure that the right resources are
available to help with any deployments
if you'd like to learn more about the
framework please download our white
paper for a deeper look and visit our
websites where we cover each solution
area in more depth and you can access
other videos in this series speaking of
the camp video series please stay tuned
and make sure you watch our upcoming
videos where they'll cover gke
optimization best practices and tools
for containers development and
modernizing Legacy applications
exciting stuff with that I want to thank
you for your time and encourage you to
get in touch with us to get started with
your camping Adventures
foreign